a gesture of solidarity as villagers
gather to pay respect to the victims of
a landslide
they are the latest casualties of the
heavy rains battering sri lanka
several homes have been buried in
landslides like these
many more livelihoods lost
a large number of people have been
affected here many of them have been
evacuated
but we've not received any relief
supplies from anyone
we live from earnings from a small shop
the shop and everything in it was
completely destroyed by the landslide
my husband had a stroke
elsewhere streets have turned into
rivers
people are forced to use homemade boats
to get around
flood waters have reached roof level
and cut off access to many villages
the natural disaster has disrupted life
for almost half a million people
rescue efforts are in full swing the sri
lankan military is air-dropping
essential supplies to the regions
unreachable by road
hundreds have been airlifted to safety
weather forecasters are predicting more
torrential rains over the next 36 hours
meaning the situation for people here
could get even worse